welcome everyone to streaming the galaxy
my name is rocket riley and today we're
going to be talking about the first
phase of the marvel cinematic universe
the first successful cinematic universe
since the alien vs predator films in my
opinion and today that's we're going to
be talking about my opinions if you
don't agree with them that's fine
because everyone is entitled to their
own wrong opinions
now the mcu is currently split into four
main phases but today we're going to be
ranking each of the films in the first
phase with this list we'll be looking to
see how each of the phase one titles
stack up against each other and in case
you haven't seen any of these films from
over 10 years ago there may be some
spoilers ahead now let's get started
with the movie that continued the
development of the most successful
cinematic universe of all time the one
that helped to launch a multi-billion
dollar franchise spread across over 25
titles
the incredible hulk
[Music]
coming in at number six on today's
ranking is the incredible hulk while i
do love this movie because it stars ed
norton one of my favorite actors and
because it has some great action
sequences it has several flaws which
drop it to the bottom of the list the
movie starts us off with bruce banner in
brazil a fugitive from the american
government and general ross one of the
two big bad guys in this film
bruce is trying to find a cure to his
hulkdom which all started because of a
gone bad experiment in the inherent
quest to find the super soldier serum
which constantly shows up throughout the
mcu films and tv shows
throughout the movie we see some cool
action sequences where bruce whose
brazilian breathing techniques can't
hold off the big greeny turns into the
hulk and throws around some tanks and
helicopters and the like
the other big bad of the movie is
abomination a hulk-like monster who gets
his powers from a sierra made with
bruce's blood this villain also seemed a
bit forced as there wasn't much time for
character development in this movie's 1
hour and 52 minute run time the fight
sequences with abomination don't do much
for me because the stakes aren't very
high and because we don't see much of
the impact or aftermath of the
destruction their battles cause
you could also tell that the screenplay
had some issues which weren't wholly
resolved there are rumors that there was
some kind of dispute between ed norton
and zach penn on different rewrites of
the screenplay and i feel like some of
the dialogue and plot development
suffered from this
although the movie had some flaws it
also had some great things going for it
the editing the pacing and the
performance by ed norton are all
fantastic
coming in at number five on today's list
is iron man 2.
[Music]
this movie has plenty to love including
ivan venko's bird tony stark's drunken
djing and justin hammer's dance moves
but first let's talk about the few flaws
with this film
in the beginning i had little sympathy
for ivan or whiplash because again there
was very little time for character
development on his end it also seems a
bit rushed to immediately put him
against the great tony stark without
much of a plan other than to make it so
that the world can see tony bleed
it also seems like many of the early
marvel films failed to accomplish the
task of making empathetic villains but
they certainly do so with many of the
later films my biggest issue with this
movie though is the fact that tony cures
his blood toxicity by creating a new
element that his dad hid in an expo
layout mock-up
like what kind of lemony snicket sort of
stuff is that i mean if my dad wanted me
to figure out how to create something as
simple as a birdhouse he would at least
leave me with an instruction book
anyways this movie did have plenty of
good things going for it too one of my
favorite scenes is when tony puts on the
iron man suit in the briefcase like when
i first saw this movie i thought that
was one of the coolest things ever the
movie does a great job of taking us down
tony's journey of realization that his
actions have consequences with him
having a bit of a death wish because of
his impending blood toxicity demise and
finally realizing that he isn't actually
invincible pushing him to make a move
with pepper i love the fight scene with
tony and rhody recast from the original
iron man film and tony and rhodey's
chemistry and back and forth throughout
the movie all in all this film is lots
of fun and it has great rewatch value
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
coming in at number four on today's list
is thor
it's drink i like it i know it's great
right
i had always felt that thor was a bit
out of place in the mcu with most of the
characters in the universe coming from a
place of science fiction rather than
fantasy or religious origins although
the movie might feel like this in the
beginning the writers and directors do a
great job of establishing thor and the
asgardian's place in the mcu
this movie went on to establish thor as
one of the central figures of the mcu
along with iron man and captain america
and he has been in a total of eight mcu
films with another coming soon thor love
and thunder this movie has plenty to
love tom hiddleston's performance as
always the set designs in world building
and chris hemsworth's bleached eyebrows
i don't have many negative things to say
about this movie except for the somewhat
slow pacing in the middle third of the
film almost every scene does a good job
of moving the plot forward or providing
some sort of information that has a
payoff later in the film
for example at one point loki goes to
tell the imprisoned thor that his
banishment was too much for his dad to
handle so he keeled over and died which
is a lie but it was all just to drive
the wound of thor being kicked out of
asgard deeper this scene could be seen
as unnecessary but it does a good job of
establishing loki as the god of mischief
always looking for a way to end up on
top or just to cause mayhem
overall this is a great movie and an
absolute must watch in understanding any
of the later mcu films
coming in at number three on today's
list is captain america the first
avenger
after re-watching this movie recently
with my wife i realized that i hadn't
seen it since it was first released in
theaters and boy am i glad that we made
the time to watch it because it is
amazing in my opinion it beats out thor
because chris evans seems like he was
just made to be captain america and fits
the role perfectly whereas looking back
chris hemsworth likely could have been
replaced with a similar actor and
performed equally as well in thor
chris evans as steve rogers though will
be stuck in my mind as the first avenger
forever this movie is very different
from all the other mcu films as well
because it takes on the somewhat
different genre of a war film most of
the stories take place in more modern
times and placing the majority of this
movie during the world war ii era gives
it a more gritty feel that i really
enjoy this movie does a great job of
character development especially with
steve rogers although we don't see much
of a change in steve's personality or
actions throughout the film we do get
the chance to learn more and more about
him and his kind-hearted nature which
just makes him so darn likable and we
get to see him develop physically very
quickly
i love the scenes of steve during basic
training getting the flag from the pole
by pulling out the pin and jumping on
the grenade because he thought it might
injure the people around him
these scenes do a great job of
establishing why he was chosen for the
super soldier program in the first place
on the other hand red skull is the
epitome of the fanciful spectacular
villain that you might see in old comic
books this translation of the comic
villain to the screen is done in such a
great nostalgic way you can almost see
jack kirby's pen touching the screen
although this movie has plenty to love
there are still two phase one titles
which beat it out
i'm gonna do this all day
coming in at number two on today's list
is the avengers
doth mother know
you whereas her drapes
the sixth film in the mcu franchise the
avengers was probably one of the most
ambitious film crossovers of all time
when it was released rivaled only by one
this movie is fantastic bringing all the
characters we have gotten to know from
the previous five films together for an
epic show stopping innovation of a film
there's so many great things in this
movie i love how loki uses the scepter
to drive the characters apart i love how
steve rogers is continually impressed by
modern technology and advancements i
love how the helicarrier becomes
invisible as it lifts into the air and i
love all of the actors performances both
individually and as a group a lot of
times in in movies with a large cast
there doesn't seem to be much chemistry
between the main characters that is
absolutely not the case with the
avengers the way they bounce off of one
another and work together to stop loki
before eating some shawarma is just so
much fun to watch there are too many
great scenes to go through in this video
but i'll leave you with this
if you ever want to understand any of
the later mcu films you must watch the
avengers
and i will not be bullied by that
[Applause]
and finally coming in at number one on
today's list is iron man
for your consideration
the jericho
iron man geez i just don't know where to
start
this movie was and still is an absolute
masterpiece in storytelling in character
development in cinematography and
computer graphics and in talent
selection
i don't think many people thought robert
downey jr was the best choice for the
character of tony stark when the movie
was in production because of his
troubled past but
now there is absolutely no one else it
could have been in my mind throughout
the movie rdj does a great job of being
arrogant and self-absorbed but you still
love the character without his delivery
and personality i feel like this movie
could have flopped and there was a ton
writing on this film we've all seen what
happens to a franchise when one movie
tanks the entire cinematic universe and
iron man was supposed to be one of the
first of its kind
john favreau's direction with tony story
arc throughout the movie from a
self-absorbed weapons dealer to a
less self-absorbed superhero is given a
thoughtful and pretty realistic approach
with many of the stunts performed and
imagery done with practical effects this
film brings the realism to a level that
many of the later mcu films lack don't
get me wrong i love a bit of escapism
but there's something about iron man
that's so grounded it makes you feel
like it's truly happening
i don't have anything negative to say
about this movie and i'm so glad the
studio took the gamble in iron man
i am iron man
well that's gonna be all for us today
guys if you enjoyed the video please
consider dropping a like and hit the
subscribe button to stay up to date on
all of our new videos also click the
bell icon to be notified whenever we
upload so you never miss a beat
if you have any ideas that you'd like to
share for future videos please drop them
below in the comment section and let us
know your thoughts on today's video
from everyone here at streaming the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching
[Music]